so you're a state government in the
early 2000s you're looking for a way to
make more money from taxes but you have
a problem you're already taxing the rich
and the middle class a lot if you make
their taxes any higher they're gonna
vote you out of office and raising taxes
on poor people is obviously not an
option unless you want rioting in the
streets
so we need a way to tax the poor without
them noticing we need a way to make poor
people want to give us their money a
strategy that will entice them so much
that they will enthusiastically give
away their cash shut up and take my
money once you start thinking about it
you quickly realize that it's actually
quite a doable and realistic way to make
money from the states all you have to do
is take advantage of poor people's weak
points the desire to get rich fast
without any efforts and their conscience
so you set up a little game called the
lottery
you dangle a huge cash prize in front of
people's faces the kind of prize that
would completely change someone's life
is something that would make them an
overnight multi-millionaire so citizens
pay a tiny fee to get a ticket to be
entered into a raffle of sorts
everyone with a ticket technically has a
chance to win the big prize did you say
130 million dollars yeah and people who
don't buy tickets are basically missing
out on the chance to win 370 million you
can't be too cool for that
all right do all right there we go you
encourage people who are struggling
financially that they could turn their
entire life around with just one lottery
tickets with just one little investments
regular people feel like they've been
given a real chance to win but in
reality you're more likely to be killed
by a vending machine than winning the
lottery
death by a vending machine
then you double down you make the game
even more enticing by telling people
that every cent they spend on tickets is
all going to a good cause educating the
youth of tomorrow you explain that every
dollar spent on the lottery will be used
to boost education funding for example
in 2006 north carolina established the
north carolina education lottery it's
the perfect appearance of a win-win
people are basically lining up around
the block to give you their money and
they can feel good about it because they
think it's all going to the children's
education when in reality you're only
giving about 30 of the lottery revenue
to education and for every dime provided
by the lottery education funding in
north carolina drops
in reality the only real winners of the
lottery are the bureaucrats and
politicians all the poor people are just
suckers they take advantage of yeah i
want my tickets too and i'm buying the
knicks and steffi graf
this is the lottery the covert tax on
poor people
lotteries are predatory they play on our
psychology to suck a stride of our
hard-earned money but what if lottery
psychology could be used for good what
if lottery psychology could be used to
incentivize you to save money and build
wealth instead of keeping you poor well
that's where yada comes in a savings
account that pays you interest in prizes
giving you a chance to win 10 million
dollars every single week it's simple
the more money you save in your yada
account the higher your odds of winning
10 million dollars every single week
they've already awarded over 6.5 million
dollars to their more than 400 000 users
it's a fun and easy way to save and
manage your money and what's great is
that there's actually a reasonable
chance you can win while government
lotteries have a 1 in 300 million chance
of winning 40 of yada users win a prize
every single week on average this
includes three tesla winners and two 38
thousand dollar cash winners i've
already won some money since i opened my
account a few weeks ago over 400 000
people are already using it and getting
started is super easy first you go to
withyada.com with the link below then
you deposit as little as 25 into your
account and for every 25 you put in you
earn one ticket every week so a 100
deposit equals four tickets
every week yada draws seven randomly
generated numbers depending on how many
numbers you match you could win anywhere
from 10 cents to 10 million dollars and
you literally can't lose because users
earn an average of 1.5 percent in their
fdic insured accounts which is way
higher than other savings accounts and
if you're feeling a little bit more
daring you can put your money into the
crypto bucket which earns a 4 average
apy in the form of more tickets and more
chances to win the more time you waste
not using yada the more money you're
losing out on so get started by clicking
the link below play the no lose lottery
by pausing the video and clicking the
link below we're proud to have yada
sponsoring this video
[Music]
the concept of a lottery seems simple
enough but you're actually using nasty
psychological tactics to make people
want to keep playing it's not as simple
as just telling people they could win
some money no it's much more deliberate
and targeted than that
first you want to make sure the public
associates lotteries with the public
good convincing people that their money
is going to a good cause tends to soften
their attitude i mean look at the stigma
attached to gambling in casinos or at
horse races regularly you never see
people looking down on the lottery like
that you use commercials to convince the
public that it's basically their civic
duty to play the lottery to date more
than 530 million dollars has been raised
for education by the north carolina
education lottery more than 140 building
projects are underway classroom sizes
have been reduced
the more at four program serving at-risk
four-year-olds has been supported and
more than 32 000 college scholarships
have been granted to need based students
we are proud supporters of education
because when you give students a chance
to succeed their world is wide open and
that is a legitimate opportunity to get
rich fast new york's powerball jackpot
is over a hundred million dollars
get the feeling new york lottery hey you
never know then you tinker with the
price size and opportunities to win
until you find the perfect recipe that
makes everyone want to play
luckily for you most people want to play
the lottery when the jackpot is the
biggest conveniently that's when their
chances of winning are the lowest
lottery sales actually decrease if the
odds of winning are too high i have a
feeling that we may win
the lottery it seems counterintuitive
but psychologically it makes sense when
a person is told they could buy a 2
ticket and possibly win 200 million
dollars they think what the heck it's
hardly even a loss and there's no chance
to win if they don't even play
it might be my lucky day very very slim
to none but you gotta have a chance if
you don't play you can't win that's
guaranteed once you have them thinking
that way they're right where you want
them
people will do everything in their
psychological power to convince
themselves that this time will be the
time that they win the jackpots all of
this makes it easier to keep taking
advantage of them in many states all the
lottery revenue comes for only a small
percentage of the population but who are
they who are the people spending over 80
billion dollars on the lottery every
year well it's the poor people of course
these are the people who we can make the
most money from it's usually the poorest
people spending the most on the lottery
the average u.s household spends around
162 dollars on the lottery every year
but people making less than 10 000 a
year spend almost 600 on the lottery
every year
people below the poverty line are
spending the most when in reality their
odds of winning are basically impossible
[Music]
let's put it into perspective the odds
of winning the lottery jackpot are
around 1 in 300 million right now there
are a little over 300 million people
living in the us so if you gave every
person in the usa lottery tickets
including babies only one person will
win still not convinced let's say you
gave every man woman and child living in
the united kingdom germany france italy
and spain a lottery tickets there would
still only be one winner and your odds
won't get any better just because you
play more you're more likely to become a
movie star 1 in 1.5 million be attacked
by a shark 1 in 11.5 million or be voted
president of the united states 1 in 32.6
million then you are to win the lottery
and yet the plebs will keep playing and
their money probably isn't going where
they think it is
[Music]
the lottery has been around for
centuries and it's always been used to
fund matters of the states lotteries
have funded 300 schools including
harvard yale and colombia ben franklin
used lottery revenue to buy cannons
lotteries were even used by the chinese
han dynasty to fund big projects like
the great wall of china today the
biggest cost that lotteries contribute
to or at least claim to contribute to is
education but it's not much the majority
of lottery money goes to taxes and
prizes for lottery winners some money is
kept for advertising and paying for
people's salaries then a state takes a
portion of the money and finally
whatever is left goes to a good cause
like education here's how it breaks down
right now 72 percent goes to price
payouts administration and retailer
prices 27 as you can see here goes to
education and 0.4 that's just that
sliver right there that goes to veteran
assistance fund and other state programs
now the most recent audit shows in the
fiscal year for 2016 that translated to
1.4 billion dollars for education but
total sales were over 5 billion dollars
so we can verify some lottery money does
go to the schools but definitely not all
of it but usually the amount they're
left with isn't making a dramatic
difference i was always under the
impression that a good part of it went
to uh the schools yeah that's right in
the classroom yeah i never really
researched it but that's what i've i've
always assumed
it could be going to teachers aids
additional staff supplies and books and
just the regular things that we parents
are buying ourselves for the classroom
so the lottery is not keeping america's
education system afloat or something
like that do you think it's misleading
to people absolutely it is misleading
and so people who buy tickets thinking
hey i'm helping education do you think
they're really doing as much as they
think they are absolutely they they
believe they are but they're absolutely
not benefiting education
our kids love to learn they're eager to
learn
and they deserve better plus it's not
like the lottery is contributing extra
money to schools the lottery gives
schools money and the education budget
gets cut by the same amounts no
additional money is actually being added
to the state school budgets we're just
redistributing who pays for it which is
now the poor people
[Music]
[Music]
today lottery sales are higher than ever
so it's important to understand what the
reality is
crime attacks on the nation's poorest
people a tax on hope
[Music]
imagine boundless possibilities
where the only limits are the limits of
one's dreams
imagine feeling lucky every single day
and hope and opportunity soaring to all
new heights
in some states the government gets more
money from lotteries than they do from
the income taxes they get from
corporations yes poor people are paying
more taxes than corporations with a
smile on their face some states even
allow people to set up part of their
paycheck to be automatically set aside
for lottery tickets the ultimate irony
is that even if you get really really
lucky even if you're the one out of 300
million people who actually does win the
lottery you'll be paying nearly 40 in
taxes on your winnings in the lottery
world the government is the house and
the house never loses but poor people
they lose every single time
and if you want a chance at actually
winning some money while building your
wealth at the same time you've got to
sign up for yada the savings account
that pays you interest in prizes giving
you a chance to win 10 million dollars
every single week they took all of this
effective lottery psychology to
incentivize you to save money instead of
giving it away where the more you save
the higher your chances of winning i've
met the founders and i've already won
some money with them after depositing
money in yada for like a week or two so
it's a really cool app and company and
remember you literally can't lose
compared to government lotteries because
you earn a 1.5 average apy in their fdic
insured accounts which is way higher
than other savings accounts or an
incredible 4 average apy if you put your
money into the crypto bucket where you
get more tickets with more chances to
win the more time you waste not using
yada the more money you're really losing
out on so get started by clicking the
link below play the no lose lottery by
pausing the video and clicking the link
below thanks to yada for sponsoring this
video
so i grew up pretty poor and when i was
a kid my parents would play the lottery
every now and then and i remember one
time where my parents won probably like
a hundred dollars or maybe like a
thousand dollars i can't remember but we
were like so happy and jumping all
around and celebrating so this video
definitely hit close to home so do you
guys play the lottery do your parents
play the lottery did you play it before
let me know in the comments below and if
you're new here my name is jake and this
is one of the biggest channels for
documentaries on money power and crime
so if you enjoyed this video we make
multiple ones of these every single week
for free so click that subscribe button
below and if you want more controversial
ones that are even longer that i can't
post publicly because they're too
controversial click that join button
below there's a refund policy so if you
join and you don't think it's worth it i
will refer you the money myself just
email me about it and that's gonna wrap
it up thank you so much for watching
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you